do you ever just even take a second and
look back at your journey from you
making your mom laugh to your working on
it's it's a it's a really beautiful Arc
working on these projects now you know
it's uh it's a it's a it's a crazy
journey to to if you look when you look
at the whole thing because anyone can
take one section they can go and watch
origin and see you and that and go oh
that's cool but when they when you see
the whole journey it's pretty
mindblowing it brings toise you know to
be honest with you uh because I'm
like it's what it says to me and what I
say to my children and them kids
downstairs is that dreams come true they
absolutely come true you know what I
mean and if you look at me you know what
I mean you know somebody who had no
background in any of it didn't know what
sketch was improv was and here I am
still 20 some OD years later still
putting on the baby hair in the in the
booty from Reno
911 you know what I mean the longest
running sketch you know bit that has
been on television I mean it's it's it's
mindblowing but I feel so much gratitude
yeah for it you know I've always heard
it was your idea to put on the
prosthetic fake booty is that true
that's a fact that's a fact because you
know why because
the women in my family I did not see
them on TV you know what I mean now you
could buy a butt on every corner you
know what I
mean you can buy one on every corner but
then it wasn't popular right to have all
of the you know what I mean and I went
to so many booty fittings like you don't
even understand and they couldn't get it
right because they were building it
straight back so I went to my girlfriend
and I brought her up there who had you
know the natural Slammer jamama and I'm
like you see you got to start from the
hips and wrap it around so I got the
booty right it was really I love that
you brought your friend in what was your
friend's
name I don't know if I should say it
okay well you just I mean it's a
compliment but I left saying to your
friend hey come on over here I your ass
I need your ass get your ass over here
literally get your ass over here
literally and you know let me tell you
something that friend of mine true story
her butt and my and my up top was how we
got uh to look Prince right in the face
we didn't have tickets to this Grammy
party he was at and I so we went around
the side and there was a a security
guard I said girl you know what to do
she started walking backwards I started
walking forward I was like come on and
we walked over there so he let us in the
back door so we get in the party and
then we lied and said that I'm always
lying to get a job right we lied and
said she was Princess cousin and so we
go oh my God the purple one was behind
this door so we knock we walk up to
security like yeah we need to get in
there um she's like I'm his cousin I'm
like yep she's his cousin yep and he he
looked at us up and down he said one
minute he closes the door and goes and
we like
the door opens it is Prince he looked at
us and before we could take a breath he
said nice try and closed the door in our
face I said but we got to see him he
said nice try to
us yeah that is so cool and I don't even
know what that had to do with the booty
but the point is it was that same girl
backwards get backwards to get in that's
how she got everything in life but she
walked backward we deny this card oh
yeah check this out the card Works
Conan's so jealous right now well okay
let's talk about this I have famously I
have no ass there's just nothing back
there it's a straight drop and I'm
thinking I should get a prosthetic is
there is there something they make for
men now make sure it's done right you
should bring a friend in who has the
right butt and then have them do
it I don't know I don't know what the
right to call my friend yeah exactly you
should come
and I should say I want this but the
point I was making is that that butt
wasn't popular back then that body type
not even the butt just the body type you
know and I wanted to be somebody that my
aunties could look at and see themselves
and so I was like I want to look like
the women in my family and I I I have to
tell you so many men met me in life
after and were so disappointed that I
didn't have the thing on they were like
you lost weight I'm like
no I can go get
it it's in the back of the car yeah keep
it with me at all times you could borrow
hers well I don't don't they make
something for men no I'm just saying you
could borrow the one she uses for Reno
911 maybe I can you have a name for it
you nicknamed it I did
not but you know my prosthetic one like
I have one that I would wear under the
uniform but the prosthetic one that I
wore with the thong bathing suit that
one um somebody stole it you bet they
did it was in a temperature control
Locker somewhere di if I knew where that
was I'd grab it and some take it on
vacation what are you yeah what are you
going to do I don't want to talk about
what I'm going to do to it that's my
business so you're invading my privacy
right now I buy two airline tickets and
the prosthetic ass is in the other one
and we both have a glass of
champagne oh my
good when you make yourself laugh you've
gone too far come back come back from
over there get from over there be
ashamed to
myself um and your life is good I mean
the thing is about you and I've talked
to you many times you're always you I
mean you've had I don't think you're any
different after all the success you're
you're you're such a real person you're
such a force I think that's the real
gift don't you think wouldn't you say
that's true like definely you're just
you haven't I know people who' have had
a lot of success and they go through a
machine and they kind of I don't
recognize them as much later on you know
what I mean I don't know if you've
encountered that but I encounter people
who but uh you are always you in the
best way you're just like this pure like
I I was in a like I was thinking about
it today like this is just going to be
we're going to have a really good time
and and that's just from experience just
from knowing you I haven't seen you
since I got newly married though that's
right you got married in two like two
years ago three now three years okay I
got married in 2020 I haven't seen you
since and I don't think I've met your
partner have I no you have not yeah no
you have not never met anyone I was
married to I mean I've seen you a couple
times I mean you know what I've been
married three times I seen you at least
through two of you always made sure that
everyone else was gone when you and I
met you
know my name is NI Nash bets and I feel
sexy about being Conan O'Brien's
friend uh your wife is Jessica is that
right yes but I I I don't call her my
wife okay I call her my
husband I love that that's my story and
I'm sticking to it yeah and how did you
guys meet oo well well we came to know
of each other in social media but the
first time we actually saw each other
face to face was on a movie set but I
was married and she was in a long-term
relationship so I didn't think nothing
about it you know what I mean right and
then some years later about four and a
half years later I was divorced she was
out of her long-term relationship and we
went to go eat crabs and the rest is
history yeah it's F I've seen you in
interviews together and you just seem so
happy yeah which makes me happy thank
you friend it's infectious this happy
thing yeah it's a good time you know we
we are here for a good time not a long
time so you got to you know hit your wag
into something that's going to make you
happy you so many great sayings they
think you've dropped like 15 great
sayings yeah we we should pull all of
these in the episode and make bumper
stickers I'll see that you get
8% that's
8% not
gross